e ormai diventata un'icona la maglia coi
ananas quindi e quindi siamo al 100 75
che fanno la rimetti perché le luci
episodi andato così bene
rimettiamo l'amico registrato questi due
episodi di fila ma fa bene a tutti i
ragazzi in prendere deve solo video sono
parigi oggi sono tanti sur les pins
siamo al 175 quindi oggi episodio
speciale abbiamo tutta la sfilza di
soliti livelli speciali ogni volta che
arriviamo a un multiplo di cinque perché
io con happy days mi insegnò anche le
tabelline oggi farei troppo droghe mi si
è fermato il cursore su droghe sarà un
segno non lo so proviamo playnow uno dei
livelli più votati when the color of the
screen changes domum del wysiwyg dai
quindi quando cambia colore dello
schermo
non bisogna muoversi o scambiano va bene
a perché sono un drogato giorno fatto è
che puoi chiamare highways puoi provare
un po di droghe questo è un veramente un
gioco family friendly chat fa cops iron
kagame ed è questa la propria classica
vociona del padre ok arcai del cliente
il figlio volevano fare invece il poi
dice sei family friends dopo l'essenza
quanto picked up e non devo muovermi
immagini non sono muoio è tutto più
bello
no ragazzi non fate la madonna però
aspetta o casinò la copertina del video
bellissimo bellissimo tutto sto fatto
fuori il modo di funghi ciao ragazzi ma
non avevo già giocato in maniera troppo
bene è la madonna e non sono skillato mi
sono mosso e sfruttato un clown in tutto
vero
quindi nostro amico ho perso solo un
braccio ma sono vivo ora circola dice
samara di the ring button a crearsi
cos'è aiuto c'è la madonna ma il suo
livello
e va beh don't worry abate ma nessuno si
sta preoccupando seriamente minchia che
tona time dal limite tutto a posto
ok capo quattrocchi 7 lingua guarda non
lo so il problema è che i ragazzi non si
sta capite una sega io sono fermo sono
immobili e immobile come ciro fa ridere
questa battuta non fa ridere ma tanto
5.000 iscritti ci si può permettere
qualsiasi cosa era muoviti ormai è
finito così quindi ho vinto sono
sopravvissuto wow
ok limbo dawn of the dead l'alba dei
morti come la madre cosa sa quante fa
quante fatte bene se facce varenne è
proprio quello che pensavo le scaramucce
una gamba incassata nella vespa stefano
d'orazio
quindi si fa qua devo capire come come
mi aggrappo alla rom non posso ce l'ho
fatta ce l'ho fatta
ce la feci ce la feci hai un elicottero
i've some su rock swing ricotta nomi mi
tengo aggrappato stiamo qua così
non so se vale uno dei livelli più
votati mie perché comunque sono i più
votati della storia però bello cioè per
carità perché continua ad accadere
porca vacca c'è traguardo di sopra lo
prendo lo prendo farei bellissimo
livello dell'anno forse perché questo
era talmente vecchio che non avevamo
previsto la giunta dell'elicottero man
che hanno aggiunto dopo quindi
facciamolo con il padre di duke così per
non saper né leggere né scrivere
let's go
credo sia non ho ben capito perché c'è
un traguardo in alto prova beh è volata
una gamba spero sia di mio figlio
un'altra e questo e karma invece dei ok
madonna stavo rischiando molto bene
tutto a posto e proprio mettersi in
piedi che difficile però lavorandoci ci
aspetta un attimo
ok c'è un sellino dentro niente sono
bella questa partenza è buona
questo continuo è molto buono molto
buono ma ragazzi ma non si può dire le
conto che non si può arrivare almeno che
non vada lentissimo devo andare lento e
cercare di andarle ma non puoi non puoi
andar lento impossibile devo cercare
andamento per arrivare alla fine in modo
tema non si può fare devo scendere un
gradino male anche se scende un gradino
alla volta perché un certo tutto prende
velocità quindi non puoi farlo devo
arrivare lento al finale ma è proprio è
difficilissimo ragazzi c'è proprio non
si può fare
ve ne rendete conto di star madonna
provata
quasi solo vivo sono vivo sono vivo
finché sono vivo vinco dovevo arrivare
al finale però va bene ho vinto con
l'elicottero me non va bene ma varrà
qualcosa drago flight school e spesso
ingiusti euro chi studia store è ok
madonna che drago bello ad e popolare
però non ho capito un si vola come si
vuol a martin garics a space chi ha sì
130 contraggo è un volo molto utile
colorista drago prova bene a posto
next non ho letto ma fa niente non sto
leggendo nulla perché io non c'è bisogno
di leggere le cose io le capisco le so
non so cosa stia succedendo in tutto
questo ma fa niente let's go importante
andare avanti ma il drago gol a sé ma 4
tema 5 aiuto restando 6 è un bellissimo
livello non capisco ma è un bellissimo
livello 7 aiuto c'è anche frontflip col
drago a gamefront il call drago
bravissimo ci sarà un traguardo prima o
poi bellissimo aiuto ok non ho capito
devo prendere tutti check point se ne
avevano titolo
tua sorella torna indietro riprende
saltiamo lo perché non hanno ne voglia
di prendere tutti però fatto veramente
bene questo silent city la città
silenziosa che è fatta di pancake o
qualsiasi cosa siano o no è fatta
benissimo fermi tutti questa delle
ragnatele non lo voglio sapere
sembra attaccato al pavimento e visioni
trovare un ascia ok all'inizio ci sarà
un ascia nascosta che non ho visto
eccola picked up
ho trovato un ascia l'ho persa mai
riuscirò a tagliare lo stesso sei molto
bene e andiamo avanti ragazzi c'è una
sedia incastrata nel muro per quale
motivo hanno imbalsamato una sedia poi
ci forum è una bomba una bomba da sé una
bomba devo starci veramente lontano
perché sia per avere ecco ecco preziosi
incastra per me era un esplosa pensavo
esplodesse no però è arrivato in forma
che sta succedendo ragazzi questi
livello è basso sulla bomba esplode
potrebbe esplodere ragazzi seri passo
sulla bomba attenzione
io non ho fatto niente ha fatto tutto da
solo ma cos'era qui non ero là io penso
ragnatele insomma sono bagni
io non ho capito niente di tutto questo
però andiamo avanti ragazzi ok dead
space facciamo l'ultimo allora the space
era un gioco dove c'erano delle persone
su un'astronave e succedevano cose
brutte su questo molto obiettivo
all'inizio di confronto è una puntata
dei teletubbies
ok tutto bene tutto a posto tutto a
posto
sono molto però è tutto calcolato
ragazzi eccoci salve poi si apre qua non
si apre
e allora io saltò devo passarci in mezzo
però impossibile
madonna non si può fare sta roba
ci provo ma non si può veramente fare
perché veramente difficile dunque i
necromorfi erano veramente mi sognavo la
notte talmente vitalmente era prodotto
store giorgio a giocare da piccoli fatti
ho avuto un sacco di in cui poi ho detto
vabbè dai giochiamo us lander e da g ho
deciso che il mio cervello tutto da
avervi un senso proprio che sto
aspettando l'ora in modo tale che si
aggroviglino insomma qualcosa sto
aspettando
ok non si possiamo fare è stata non si
può passare sto punto che sfiga madonna
è diventata una nord veramente peso va
beh peccato dai c'è un velocissimo da
fare perché volevo fare conclude con la
vittoria almeno almeno una vita bmw che
non so cosa sia ma almeno conclude con
una vittoria legale almeno quello porca
vacca perché non si poteva fare quella
parte della nostra votato mila domini
polmonari sono invece una storia
scarfone strano è in genere iscrivetevi
a quell'ora c'era qualcosa di
particolarmente strano
ok ok spigea sia ok una donna per un
attimo pistole bombe ho detto no però
che i signori questo era apre al chelsea
165 dispiace per lei sono seccato un po
però gli sia piaciuto ragazzi
iscrivetevi a creare sia cela campani
mia prima ragione i suoi video troppo
uscirà è primi due fra domani e spero
che stia domani ci vediamo per sei
episodi scritti anche rai tre da ragazzi
[Musica]